[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الجزيره تحصل على تفاصيل
رد حماس على مقترح اتفاق التهدئه ومصادر
للجزيره تقول ان الحركه وافقت على اتفاق
للتوصل الى هدنه تامه ومستدام على ثلاث
مراحل بلينكن يبحث مع المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين جهود الافراج عن الاسرى
ومكتب نتنياهو يقول ان مباحثاته مع بلينكن
كانت طويله ومعمق وجانسو نتنياهو يماطل
ويضر باهداف الحرب تجدون المزيد من اخبار
حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول اربعه قتلى ونحو 16 مصابا جراء سقوط
شضايا صواريخ روسيه على مبان سكنيه وسط
كيف والجيش الاوكراني يقول انه تمكن من
اسقاط صواريخ وطائرات مسيره في احدث هجوم
روسي استهدف مقاطعات اوكرانيه في الاثناء
نبه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى ان
الوقت ينفد بالنسبه لاوكرانيا في مواجهه
روسيا وحتى الكونغرس على الموافقه عاجلا
على حزمه جديده من المساعدات
لكيف الامم المتحده تعلن حاجتها الى اكثر
من اربعه مليارات دولار خلال العام الحالي
لتوفير مساعده انسانيه لملايين السودانيين
داخل البلاد ومن لجوا الى د مجاوره موضحه
ان نصف سكان السودان اي نحو 25 مليون شخص
يحتاجون الى دعم
وحمايه محكمه بريطانيه تقر في حكم وصف
بالتاريخي باهميه حمايه الاراء المناهضه
للصهيونيه بعد ان حكمت لصالح الاستاذ
الجامعي ديفيد ميلر مقره بتعرضه للتمييز
عقب فصله من جامعه بريستول بسبب ارائه
المناهضه للصهيونيه وانتقاده اسرائيل
المحكمه قالت ان التعبير عن الاراء
المناهضه للصهيونيه محميه بموجب قانون
المساواه في البلاد الى
اللقاء